hey this is Mel and in this lecture I'm
going to be talking about some of the
evidence for global warming and so in
this class you've been reading this book
and so far you've read parts one two
three and four
we've got exam number three coming up
and an exam number three we're going to
be focusing on among other things the
evidence for global warming
now you've been reading about other
things and some of that some of those
other things will be in exam number four
so what I want to do in this lecture and
the one that follows is go through some
of these diagrams the charts the maps
that have been in your book and some of
the concepts and try to explain in more
detail what they're talking about here
and hopefully they'll make a little more
sense so to start here's an example of a
graph that was in your book and yours is
is very similar to this it may not look
quite exactly like it but on the y-axis
that says temperature difference
compared to the 1951 to 1980 mean and
there's a bunch of red dots here and
each dot by itself represents a global
temperature for for a whole year
compared to a 30-year average okay so
there's a lot kind of embedded in this
and I want to make sure we all
understand what they're what they're
showing here okay so first of all each
red dot imagine how complicated it would
be to try to come up with one number to
represent the temperature of the earth
you've got all the different locations
you've got the different seasons and you
throw all that together over a whole
year and you come up with one number and
that's not easy to do now with modern
records it's pretty easy with satellite
data we have satellites that can measure
the temperatures of the surface of the
earth and come up with a number pretty
easily when you go further back in time
because it gets
harder you've got to rely on weather
stations on the ground and weather
stations on ships and buoys and it's you
know you have to kind of integrate all
these measurements and people have
argued about exactly the best way of
doing it and we don't have time to
really dig into the details about how
that is done except we kind of have to
accept that they know what they are
doing when they came up with these with
these numbers so that's the first thing
is every red dot is one number for the
whole planet for the whole year the
other thing that they've done instead of
saying that the global average
temperature is a particular number like
54 degrees Fahrenheit or whatever it is
they're not doing that they're comparing
it to a 30-year average now remember we
said in an earlier lecture that 30 years
is a number that we use for calculating
climate we have this term climate norm
climate normal it's a 30-year average so
what they've done here is they've taken
all the temperatures for the world from
1951 to 1980 so that's a 30-year average
and they average the whole thing
together and came up with one number
whatever that is let's just say it's 54
degrees Fahrenheit and then they said
okay how much did this one vary compared
to that average now they're doing
maitland degree centigrade so the
numbers above zero so this dot right
here would be 0.2 degrees centigrade
above the 1951 to 1980 average okay
so between 1951 which would be right
about here in 1980 which would be right
about there
these Nevers are bouncing back and forth
they're hovering around the zero mark
because that's how they actually defined
this graph they're comparing it to this
30-year average so the numbers that are
in that 30 year time period are going to
be pretty close to zero on the other
hand you have these numbers that are
negative and what that means is that
these years were colder than this 30
years so it's in my opinion it's a very
confusing way to show data like this but
this is how it's done so we kind of have
to
get in the mind of a climate scientist
they always want to compare something to
a 30-year average so they picked this
this segment for their 30 years and
they're calculating each year and
they're comparing it to that 30 year
average
so negative just means we were colder
than this 1950 to 1980 average and the
positive numbers means that we're warmer
compared to that 1950 the 1980 average
okay but the actual number isn't so
important as the trend so a big idea
that I want you to get out of this class
is that when we talk about climate
change we're looking for long-term
trends in the data okay that's a huge
idea here so if you go to year to year
right so if I just pick some some
arbitrary year here and I say well here
the temperature relatively was
relatively low it jumps up and then it
goes back down and back up and back down
and year to year it doesn't show that
it's actually getting warmer every
single year and this is a huge
misconception some people say well
global warming must mean it's getting
warmer every year but what this graph
shows is no it's not getting warmer
every year this year right here was
colder than the year before right and so
some climate change critics or global
warming critics would say a hot seat
global warming is not real because we
actually have years that were colder
than the prior year therefore it can't
be getting warmer but that's not what we
mean by global warming what we mean is
that if you look at this graph what's
the overall trend the overall trend as
things are going up and up and up and
yes there are year two your average of
changes why for example do we have these
white you know why was it warm this year
and then dip down it the year after a
lot of this has to do with El Nino La
Nina so an El Nino you're exposing a big
part of the equatorial Pacific warm
water to the atmosphere that helps
warming the planet a little bit in along
Nina you expose a lot of cold water
along the equatorial region that makes
the pine a little bit cooler so a lot of
this kind of crazy up-and-down is long
Nina El Nino we kind of in our minds
have to kind of filter that out and say
okay yeah there's a lot of crazy up and
down but what's the overall trend and
the overall trend is higher and higher
and higher temperatures okay it's worth
pointing out there is something weird
happening here and we did talk about
this in the book a little bit we were
you can kind of kind of get from this
that from about you know 1910 or so
onwards we're warming and then in the
40s we kind of cool off a little bit
until the 70s and we start to get warmer
again right well why did this cooling
happen this is air pollution the air
pollution around the planet got so bad
it was actually reflecting sunlight and
cooling things down and you remember in
a previous lecture in the 1970s we
passed the Clean Air Act in this country
and that helped clean the air quite a
bit in other countries around the world
we didn't really talk about them but
started to also pass similar laws so we
see that the atmosphere is actually
starting the cleaner after 1970 and that
pollutions going away and we see the
warming then coming back as a result
okay so big picture here global warming
doesn't mean it's getting warmer every
year it means that the overall trend is
increasing temperatures the fact that
you have a year that's colder than the
year before does not invalidate global
warming it's just it is some noise and
the data that's what we say also they do
climate scientists typically do this
funny thing where they compare it to a
30-year average so if you're colder than
that 30 year average you end up with
negative numbers and that kind of like
if you're not used to these coming
graphs it doesn't make a lot of sense
okay another type of graph that you saw
was looking at the warming in your book
so this is on page
35 and it says changing global surface
temperature 1901 to 2012 and it says
under that notice that the pattern of
warming is not uniform land regions for
example have warm more than the oceans
okay so there's a couple things I really
want you to get from this first of all
this gray how it's gray down here that's
gray up here that means that we haven't
had temperature records that are robust
enough for long enough to be able to
save for scientific certainty what's
happening now in a minute I will show
you some graphs where we we do kind of
know what's happening here but for this
one since nineteen no you know back in
1901 there weren't a lot of people
taking temperatures in the North Pole or
the Antarctic right so we can't say a
hundred percent for a certain what's
changed there and so that's why this is
great that doesn't mean there's no
warming it just means we don't have
records of it also you'll see some other
places in here with this in gray like in
the middle of Africa again 1901 nobody's
taken temperatures in the middle of
Africa and making really nice records so
one of the big points that I want you to
get from this is that the warming is not
distributed evenly you see a lot more of
it on the continents than you do in the
oceans and you see a lot more of it in
the northern hemisphere than you do in
the in the south so that's one thing I
can just notice the other thing is if
you look at the scale down here they're
looking for changes over this you know
one hundred and twelve year period blue
means it got a little bit colder in that
hundred years and all these other colors
means that it's gotten warmer and you'll
notice that right up here there is a
little blob of blue which means that in
fact there's a couple little specks over
here too and so what this means is that
the the world is actually there's a
couple places where the world has gotten
a little bit cooler in the last hundred
years according to this now a climate
change critic will say aha see that
global warming must not be true because
if the world was getting warmer
then you wouldn't expect places to
actually be getting colder okay so this
is another misconception about global
warming global warming does not mean the
entire globe is getting warmer even
though that's kind of the implication
so what global warming actually means is
that if you mathematically average this
whole thing right take all the colors
into account and you were to add it all
up what would then that result be right
if you look at all the oranges and
yellows and Red's yeah there's a couple
little specks here where it's a little
bit blue right and those are those are
where it's gotten cooler but if you
averaged this whole thing the globe was
definitely getting warmer it's a
mathematical average now why would it
actually beginning colder in places like
how why would that even happen so there
was a couple reasons one is you could
have it shift in ocean currents so if
you remember the Gulf Stream the Gulf
Stream comes out here and it takes warm
water to the north
well that Gulf Stream is becoming weaker
with the time which means it's pumping
less warm water to the North Atlantic
and therefore this region up here is
getting cooler here's another version of
this map that is not in your book but
it's similar to and this one is a little
different what they're doing is they are
again comparing out the temperatures
today to a 1951 to 1980 mean right so
they're taking a 30-year average and
they're looking at temperatures today am
i today I mean I think this is a couple
years old now and comparing how the
earth is now compared to that thirty
year period in the past right so if you
do that this is more modern this doesn't
go all the way back to 1901 so we have
more modern records and we see that a
lot of the warming the majority of the
warming is up in the north okay up in
the above the Arctic Circle we also see
there's more warming over the continents
in the oceans and we also see more zones
here of cooling right there's more
cooling here
in the oceans and again ye you know does
this invalidate global warming no if I
mathematically average this whole
picture together I still get a number
that's positive right it's the whole
thing on average is getting warmer even
though there's places that are getting
cooler so again why would places
beginning cooler there's several things
that could be at play here
you could have changing ocean currents
you could also have changing patterns of
storms so think about the mid-latitude
cyclones if you change the direction of
a mid-latitude cyclone so let's say you
increase the likelihood that the path of
the mid-latitude cyclone will come down
here this region down here will have
more cloudy days and have in it we'll
end up with lower temperatures so when
you see these zones out in the oceans
that are cooler doesn't mean the Earth's
getting cooler it just means we're
probably changing directions of storms
or directions the ocean currents which
are changing zones out in the ocean but
not necessarily changing the overall
pattern around the earth in terms of the
overall temperature change okay so this
is a map that's not in your book but
it's pretty important and what we're
looking at is warming and this map is
actually for the past few decades and
we're looking at how much the atmosphere
has changed temperature so this says
troposphere up here and what we're
looking at really is what how the
temperature is about 10 kilometers above
our head has changed okay that's what
they're showing so the colors are
similar as the other maps red means that
it's getting warmer blue means it's
gotten colder white means it hasn't
changed grey means we don't any data
okay so notice that there's some big
differences between this one and that
and the last maps we were looking at so
one difference is you don't see the big
contrast so much between the continents
and the oceans right you still kind of
notice more warming appeared to the
north but the big thing I want you to
pay attention to on this map is how we
have a band that's right through here
and we have another band
that's right through here okay so in
other words all of this pink has been
getting warmer but the areas that have B
have been getting especially warmer are
centered kind of right through here and
right through here so I want you to
think about something that we talked
about in a previous lecture that kind of
lines up with this and this and if you
can remember what we talked about in
global circulation in that lecture as we
talked about how air rises along the
ITCZ which is kind of near the equator
but then it sinks back down about 30
degrees north 30 degrees south those are
called the subtropical highs and they
change with the seasons okay well great
for here that's about 30 degrees south
and right up here is about 30 degrees
north so what we see for example is like
right through here this is one of the
subtropical highs and we see that it's
gotten even warmer than the surrounding
area this is where we expect to find the
Bermuda high it's gotten even warmer
than usual this is where we expect to
find the Pacific subtropical high it's
gettin warmer than usual and even here
over the continent is also part of the
Pacific subtropical high sometimes so
what does this mean
sinking air warms okay we talked about
that a long time ago if I have the
Hadley cell air rises at the equator
sync song 30 degrees right that's the
whole the whole Hadley cycle if I make
the Headlee cell bigger and stronger I
have more air rising at the equator
which means I have more air sinking at
30 degrees which means I have more of
the compressed air warming than I did
before okay so so in a you know in a
world where there's no global warming
okay we we expect air to rise at the
equator we expect air to sink at 30
degrees and as it sinks down at worms
but that's it it's reaching up
state of equilibrium right well this is
what this is saying is that those Hagley
cells are getting stronger they're
getting bigger and they're getting
stronger and even though it's getting
warmer everywhere we're seeing
especially large amounts of warming
where the Headlee cells are coming down
and making those subtropical highs
you're compressing more and more air
coming down which makes it warmer at
this ultimately will make it warmer and
drier at the surface okay so why would
this happen if you mark the whole planet
remember why is air rising at the ITCZ
in the first place that's the warmest
part of the earth that's where the trade
winds converge so if you warm up the
whole planet this part along the equator
at the surface is getting warmer more
air is rising more air goes up to the
stratosphere more air sinks down about
30 degrees north south and when you get
stronger subtropical highs so what does
that mean for us well remember we are
living under the influence of the
Pacific subtropical high especially in
the winter and the spring in the fall
right it moves out of the way in the
summer but the rest of the year it
really dominates our weather us in New
Mexico in the southwest so if that gets
stronger then what does that mean for
our weather that means that our Pacific
our Pacific subtropical high will be
getting stronger we'll see more days of
clear skies less days of rain so overall
what this is telling us is as global
warming continues and as the Headlee
cells are getting stronger we can expect
more clear skies and less precipitation
in the future so another way that we can
look at evidence for climate change is
to look at something that we call a time
series of temperature in the very first
graph we started off with in this
lecture was a time series of temperature
for the whole planet but you have a
project this week and it's involves
making a time series of temperature for
a particular location and so I'm going
to kind of
show you how that's done and show you
the type of graphs that you're going to
be making so we can divide up the
country into these areas called climate
divisions and it kinda looks like
counties but they're bigger than
counties and all the areas within a
climate division are supposed to have
similar climates there's something
similar about them they have similar
topography or elevation or something and
so we kind of group them all together so
within each climate division you might
have say several hundred operating
weather stations and usually these
weather stations are recording data at
least once an hour sometimes once every
15 minutes or even more often than that
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to pull records from a climate
division and we're going to look at we
can look in what's how the temperatures
have changed in the past so here's an
example of a record that I pulled from a
climate division called the northern
mountains division so if I go back here
this blob right here that's the northern
mountains division and so what I've
asked this to do and this is what you'll
be doing on your project is I've
generated a series of these each one of
these as red dots represents a month of
data from hundreds of weather stations
across this whole region of the northern
mountains division okay so this dot
right here means that the computer went
to the database and it looked at all the
records for this month and so this is
December of 2014
ok and it looked at all the records kept
by all the weather stations in this area
day night the whole thing averaged the
entire thing together and come up with
one number for that entire month and
that's what's plotted here okay so every
one of these dots is one number for the
entire month of that particular year
averaged over this broad area with all
those weather stations which are
recording these are usually day/night at
least once an hour
okay so this is what this record looks
like and I went back a few years and you
can see there's this up down up down and
that's just the seasons right so summer
winter summer etc right and so from this
record if I asked you do you see any
evidence of climate change it'd be
pretty tough to see anything because
it's just what you're seeing is the
seasonal swing right okay so now what
I'm going to do is I'm going to go back
more years so now I'm going to go back
20 years and look at how the
temperatures have been changing so now
again you can see summer winter summer
winter and again if I asked you do you
seen the evidence for changes it's
probably kind of hard to see a lot here
there's a lot of crazy up and down what
if I go back even further so now I'm
going back to 1940 so at first it just
looks like a crazy bunch of up and down
lines but you can start to use this
graph like this to notice a few changes
with time so let's look at the winners
okay so there's these horizontal lines
like here's a line this is 24 degrees
notice how many winners in the past got
colder than this 24 degree line right
and then notice what happens after 1990
you see no more winners get colder than
that 24 degree line now let me add what
remember what this means that 24 that
dot right there doesn't mean the winner
got down the 24 degrees once that's
average day and night over a whole month
right the entire month averaged below 24
degrees that's what that's what we're
talking about here but notice you can
see that how often that winners got down
to that 24 degree line and how often
they went below that in the past and
then starting about 1990 yeah there's a
few that reached that line but nobody
gets any colder below that or you could
look at the summers and say ok notice
that
you know here's a 69 degree line for
reference and you can see how often the
summers reach that 69 degree line and
either met it or maybe one a little bit
past it and if he again you just kind of
or just eyeballing this notice how much
white space there is between say the
sixty-four degree line and the 69 degree
line and then notice how much closer
these recent summers are to that 69
degree line there's a lot less of that
white space in here and you can kind of
see really the the number of summers
that that surpassed that 69 degree line
maybe isn't that that different but you
can see that overall they're getting
closer and closer to 69 degree line and
again 69 degrees doesn't sound that warm
but this is averaged over days and
nights and we're in the northern
mountains so the lot of these high
elevation data or you can even go
further back so now what I've done is
I've gone all the way back to 1908 right
so I've got a hundred years of data here
and I'm gonna use the same tricks notice
how often that winters got colder than
24 degrees in the past and then notice
that that stops over here and then
notice how often we get close to that 69
degree summer and then notice how often
we do it in modern times so you can just
kind of eyeball these and notice if
there's any changes in the long-term
trend there's obviously a lot of noise
what we call noise in this where we had
warm years and cool years and warm years
and cool years but what's the overall
trend that's what we're interested in
we're talking about climate change so
here's another one for example coming
from now we're in the Cascade Mountains
in Washington State and we're looking at
a hundred years of data and I'm the same
tricks notice how often the winners got
below this 22 degree mark right you see
these cold winters and they notice
starting in the 80s you no longer see
that right and in fact it's starting in
the 90s they don't
even hardly get below this 27 degree
line on the other hand we can look at
the summers how often did the summer has
breached the 62 degree mark notice how
much white space there is between the 57
and the 62 and then see what happens
here that we start to get summers that
are warmer than the 62 degree mark and
that white space between those two lines
disappears and so we're seeing a shift
towards warmer and warmer summers and
warmer and warmer winters and in fact
when we do the math with global warming
the biggest changes that we're seeing in
terms of temperatures as we're seeing
warmer nights and we're seeing warmer
winters yeah we're seeing some warmer
summers too but the biggest change like
mathematically that's happening is the
winners are getting warmer and the
nights are getting warmer and that's due
to the extra greenhouse gases okay so
besides just eyeballing some data that's
going up and down then trying to figure
out whether it's increasing or
decreasing scientists have more
quantitative ways of dealing with this
and I'm going to teach you one method
that we use it's called a running mean
or a running average so here's an
example here we've got temperatures from
days azar going by so let's just say
that each one of these dots represents
the average temperature for that 24 hour
period so we get a temperature on the y
axis we've got days on the on the x axis
and when I look at this data I can see
there's a lot of up and down right so so
temperatures are going up and down and
what I like to know is is there a
overall increasing trend or decreasing
trend or no trend in this okay that's
what we're trying to figure out so what
I'm going to do is apply something
called in this case I'm gonna call this
a five-day running average okay all
right so here's how this works first I'm
going to take the first five days one
two three four five and I'm going to
make like a window
of this first five days of data and I'm
gonna calculate what the average is of
that five I'm gonna plot it in the
middle of the window okay so my first
five points are 34 40 137 no five six
seven 38 sorry 38 42 and 45 so I just
add those all up I divide by 5 and I get
an answer of 40 okay so the average of
all these is 40 so I'm gonna plot it
right in the center of my window so
there is my first point all right so I
just took the average of five plot it
plot it in the middle okay so now I'm
gonna take this this window and here's
the key I'm gonna move it over one day
okay so I'm gonna draw another one right
here here's my new window okay so I just
shifted it over one day and I'm gonna
calculate the whole thing all right so I
got 41 and 38 and 42 and 45 and 34
divided by 540 again okay so my new my
new window my new calculation come is
exactly same answer as it was before
so I plot that in the middle so then I'm
gonna shift it over one more so over one
more and again I'm gonna calculate this
new batch so 3847 45:34
and now a new point is 40 3/5 41.4 so
now the center of this window 41.4
something like this so I'm starting to
build this new graph of red dots that is
the long-term trend and so what I see is
it at first there's basically no change
in the long-term trend now starting to
move up and I can keep doing this by
moving this window over and over and
over and doing this calculations over
and over and over and I'll get another
line that tells me what the long-term
trend is it's called a running average
or a running mean very tedious to do
this by hand but easy for a computer to
do so part of what you're going to do in
your project is when when you get some
of these temperature records you're
gonna tell it to calculate the running
mean and it will just put it on your
graph so I'll show you some examples
here so here's an example of one of
these graphs where I have used a running
mean and I just asked the computer to do
it I didn't do any math myself and this
is a 12 month running mean and it
produces this blue line so it takes
every red point and takes six months
ahead and six months behind and
calculates what that running mean is and
plus it is blue okay so now what you can
see is the running mean and we're back
in northern mountains division the
running mean is bumping up and down
between this 44 degree mark and the 49
degree mark right it's kind of down here
and then you see when you get to the 90s
it stays closer to this 49 degree mark
and doesn't ever go back down to this 44
degree mark so the long-term average has
increased its average from somewhere
kind of down in here to somewhere up in
here okay or another example here's one
from Arizona and so here the again
12-month running mean you can see that
it's
we're here in the you know it's bouncing
back and forth between 61 and 63 degrees
back in the early part of the 20th
century and then when we get to the last
20 years it's now jumped up between the
61 and 63 did or sorry the 63 and a 65
degree mark up in here okay so we've
seen a shift in the overall long term
trend so this is how you're gonna use
the running mean you can you can have
the computer calculate it and look at it
and see if there's any trend now what if
there was no trend if there was no trend
then what we would see is we might see
some up and down the beginning of the
century and it just kind of remained
that same pattern all the way across
until today and that's how you would
know if there's any long-term trends in
the data so when climate scientists are
talking about global warming what we're
looking at is we're looking at actual
temperature measurements for the most
part and so in modern times say the last
30 years that comes from mostly
satellite data we've got satellites that
can measure the entire temperature of
the earth every day you go before
satellites then you're looking at
weather station data and before that
just thermometers and the farther back
you go the more difficult it is to
really get some good data now as
scientists that's what we look at when
we're trying to figure out whether the
earth is actually warming or not and
there are some in in popular media a lot
of times you'll hear that the reason
that scientists know that the earth is
warming is because of glaciers are doing
this or the polar bears are doing that
and those are effects of global warming
but that's not really the evidence the
evidence really comes from the
temperature data but I want to talk
about some of this other evidence
because you'll hear about that and one
of the things that we can look at that
lets us know that the earth is warming
is the decrease of ice on earth okay so
one example is we can look at how much
snow is on the ground in the northern
hemisphere during the spring
and one of the themes of this whole
lecture is that when we're talking about
climate change we're not looking at
what's happening from one year to the
next but it's the long-term right and so
you can see from this that from year to
year we have years where there is
relatively high amount of snow and then
we have relatively low amount and it
bounces back and forth but the overall
trend is kind of this downhill slope
here and if we go to something like the
Arctic sea ice which is the sea ice up
around the North Pole you know here's a
graph looking at the Arctic summer sea
ice extent and again we see ups and
downs but there's this overall trend
headed downhill so that's kind of what
we're seeing for climate change and
again just to reiterate we're not
looking at this and concluding that the
earth is getting warmer we're looking at
the temperature data and concluding the
earth is getting warmer but this is
another thing that we can see as
evidence so here is a animation showing
the extent of the Arctic sea ice from
year to year and I'm gonna I've got it
paused right now but just orient
yourself so here's Canada there's Alaska
right there and then here's Siberia and
notice how close the ice is to the
margins of these continents okay and
this is these images you're going to see
is during is is the extent of the ice in
the summer okay so in the winter it
pretty much always reaches out to the
extent of the of the boundaries here
okay so let me let me play this so year
two here notice how the margins of the
ice change and some years are colder and
there's more ice some years are warmer
there's less ice but we're looking for
the overall trend and notice that in
some summers the ice actually doesn't
even reach the land masses in some
instances which meaning which means it
opens up the Seaway dad didn't used to
be there okay now this is a little
obsolete ends in 2011 since this was
made
the sea ice is actually decreased even
more now we're going to look at the same
data except we're also superimposing a
time series graph and this is again to
illustrate the point that I keep trying
to make which is that climate change is
not something we observe year-to-year
it's a long term trend and so even
though we can see that you know some
years there is more ice in some years
there's less the overall trend is one of
going downhill and that's what they're
showing here on this plot that they
superimposed on the same movie that we
just saw okay
so along with that is the fact that
we're seeing a lot more melting of
continental glaciers than we saw
previously and so Greenland is one of
the examples where you know Greenland is
one of these places that we've been
drilling ice cores because it has not
melted for hundreds of thousands of
years and yet now we're seeing sort of
record amounts of Greenland starting to
melt and it makes for some very
spectacular photos like this waterfall
here but that's not supposed to be
happening and you know it's it's kind of
a shocking amount of ice that's been
melting so here's just a three-year
study from 2004 to 2007 Greenland lost
amount of ice equivalent to 14 States of
course they picked little States but
still each of these 3 feet thick you
know that's a significant amount of ice
that that it lost now there's still a
lot there so it's not going to be
disappearing you know even in a few
years it's going to take a while but
we're seeing record amount of ice melt
coming off of Greenland in the springs
and summers so here's a Renu's report
from a couple years ago scientists
incredulous at normally high numbers for
April record melting across 12% of the
ice sheet so that's more than they'd
ever seen before this time of year also
we can look at glaciers and we can we
can we can look at where the glaciers
were about a hundred years ago so I've
got some before-and-after images and
again if you if you watch media popular
media programs on climate change they'll
kind of frame this as scientists look at
this and we can tell that global warming
is happening because of this I want to
emphasize that this is one of the
effects of global warming but but this
is not great data for scientists this is
one of the effects so here we are a
glacier so before and after picture 100
years apart you can see the glacier in
the foreground and nothing left but a
little patch of snow in the background
on on the modern picture here's another
one from 1920 again you can see the
glacier here
and this little ice field about a
hundred years later this glacier here it
isn't in the background no sign of it
anymore or this one which is now way
back there and you can see these you
know pictures from like this all over
the place where there where there are
glaciers that there's if you look a
hundred years ago you see this big
difference right so here's Olympic
National Park that before I'm sorry the
before and the after right or this one
the before and there it is way in the
background the after this is a little
bit of a confined of a confusing image
we're looking down from space this is
the top that glacier flow downhill this
way and this is it melting and chunks of
ice are floating in the water here so
these lines are what we call the old
terminus this is where the glacier used
to be so in the 1851 this is where the
glacier ended this was the terminus and
then as you you know 1902 this is the
terminus headed uphill 2000s it's up
here the last mark on there is actually
over ten years old now it's 2006 and
they need to update this image but the
glacier is now somewhere back here so
it's been retreating every year more or
less as as a climate has gotten warmer
other evidence that the for our warmer
temperatures is that the sea level is
rising okay now our records of sea level
get more more sketchy the further back
we go so you'll see there's several
lines here so this is year 1900 this is
millimeters above they picked a 30-year
average again they didn't tell us where
it was but there's a 30-year average
that they're comparing this to and
they're comparing how much global sea
average has changed some particular
thirty year period and there's different
lines because they've been measuring
different different ways if there's
different techniques for trying to
figure out the global sea level and then
suddenly you see the lines get thinner
and that's because we start measuring
them from satellites and it becomes a
lot more accurate now your book talked
about
this a little bit but just to make sure
you didn't miss it there's two reasons
why the oceans are rising number one is
the one that everybody probably can
guess if you melt ice that ice goes into
the sea and the sea level rises right
you melt glaciers sea level goes up but
that's actually the smaller component
the more significant reason is because
when you warm up water it actually
expands a little bit so as the oceans
get warmer the entire oceans in all of
it is starting to expand just from
warmer temperatures so those two things
together are why the oceans are rising
now once we got satellites that could
measure the ocean from basically it's
like using radar where they beam down
then they hit the ocean they bounce back
and they can measure it pretty precisely
we got satellites that can do that
starting in the early 90s and what you
can see the dark blue is kind of up and
down changes year to year of the sea
levels but if you the red line is sort
of the trend line the overall trend and
the overall trend is that the seas have
been increasing it about three point
four millimeters per year okay so that's
not huge right three point four
millimeters that's not a lot but it's
starting to add up over the decades and
especially is becoming noticeable if you
live pretty close to sea level so this
is not a hurricane or anything weird
this is just a high tide the town in
Florida that's built pretty close to sea
level and we can see that now the ocean
is starting to come in where it didn't
used to come before in fact there are
these cities along Florida where places
that didn't hardly ever used to flood
except in rare events are starting to
flood on a regular occurrence now then
water's coming up in the storm drains
and you know it's not coming from the
ocean it's coming up the storm drains in
flooding the streets now because those
areas are now starting to become below
sea level when they didn't used to be
another way that you can see this is
again just another example from from
Virginia and Norfolk so this is along
the coast and they this is kind of a
weird graph it's our
per year of flooding in this particular
neighborhood so somehow or another I
don't know who thought of this but they
started recording how many hours per
year this particular neighborhood was
under flooding and so back in the 30s is
when they started this and you can see
that as time has gone on they see more
and more hours of flooding in this
neighborhood again this is not great
data for scientists because there could
be other things that contribute to
flooding in the neighborhood how you you
know how the streets are being
maintained and how the storm sewers are
being maintained and all that kind of
stuff but it's just another illustration
of how rising sea levels are affecting
some neighborhoods so to conclude we've
got evidence that the temperatures are
increasing in the summers in the winters
and the days and the nights especially
during the nights especially during the
winters we see it over the continents
especially we see where the oceans some
we see it up in the atmosphere we've
talked about all those things also what
we've seen in the previous lecture is
that greenhouse gases are higher now
than they've been in the past million
years or so probably more but we can say
for sure in the past million so we know
the temperatures are higher than they've
been in a long time
we know that greenhouse gases are higher
than they've been in a long time we know
how greenhouse gases work so the
question is are can we say a hundred
percent sure that the extra greenhouse
gases are changing the climate or could
there be some other factor at work so
what is another way that Mother Nature
could possibly change the climate how
could we make the earth warmer it if
it's not humans producing greenhouse
gases what else could it possibly be
well one thing it could possibly be are
sunspots so the Sun turns out is not at
a constant luminosity it goes through
these 11-year cycles of sunspots and the
Sun has these magnetic storms and
they're not very well understood but
what we do know is that the Sun has
these cycles of eleven years where it
goes through periods of
or sunspots and then periods of less
sunspots now here is what is
counterintuitive when you have a sunspot
the sunspot is dark because it's cooler
than the surrounding area
and you'd think okay if the Sun has more
sunspots it should be cooler but it
turns out that when there are sunspots
the area surrounding the sunspot is
actually extra hot and makes up for the
sunspot and more than makes up for it so
when you have a Sun with more sunspots
the Sun is actually hotter by a few
degrees and it's not huge but it's
enough to make a difference of the
climate on earth so more sunspots means
a hotter Sun and again that's
counterintuitive you'd probably think
that more sunspots would be a cooler Sun
so people have been noticing counting
sunspots ever since the telescope was
invented and so here's an example of a
peak where there's a peak in the 11-year
cycle and then a decrease in that
11-year cycle then the peak 11 years
later and so forth so every 11 years we
have a peak in the sunspot cycle and
then ago they decrease again so here is
a movie of sunspots and before I start
it notice they've got yellow and they've
got blue here and sunspots have a north
and a south so they're magnetic and so
that's what the two colors mean and
we're going to look at a quick movie
time-lapse of several years of sunspots
so it's going to rotate at first to show
you here's the an active Sun with a lot
of sunspots and then it's going to kind
of split it apart so you can see the
whole Sun is a big map and then it's
going to play ok Dec 3 2013 7 years
later and then they disappear there's
that here comes the next cycle so every
11 years we see this maximum and then
back down to minimum again that's the
sunspot cycle
and each time it does that the Sun is a
little bit warmer during the maximum a
little bit cooler during the minimum so
one of the things that Galileo did as
soon as even into telescope is he
started observing sunspots so we've got
an actual record of sunspots all the way
back to about 1610 is when he started
doing this and one of the weird things
that happened in the late 1600s is the
sunspots went almost disappeared
completely for several decades like half
a century it's called the maunder
minimum and for whatever reason the Sun
went into kind of a relatively low
activity state and we had very few
sunspots decade after decade
well that period of low sunspot activity
corresponds to something that we call
the Little Ice Age and it was a period
where the earth was actually a little
bit cooler than usual
not full-on Ice Age with like glaciers
coming down and all that but if you look
at the historical records farmers had a
hard time during the Little Ice Age a
lot of crops failed because the earth
was relatively cooler than it was
supposed to be and then we also see
there some other times say in the early
1800s where the sunspot number was a lot
lower than it was supposed to be and and
there was a measurable cooler earth just
by maybe half a degree or something like
that but it makes a difference well so
some critics of modern day global
warming science will say that Oh the
reason the earth is getting warmer today
is because of sunspots okay so let's
look at that so we count sunspots today
and this curve followed by this curve or
the last two solar cycles so the so this
is the last solar cycle and this is the
one before that so the one before that
peaked in about 2000 2001 and the black
dots are how many solar how many
sunspots are being counted and the blue
is like a running mean so they're using
the same math that we did earlier so you
can see okay it looks like the the
sunspot cycle back in 2000 2001 peak
that
you know whatever 125 whether whatever
this level is here here's so then the
the sunspots decrease right so that's
this part and then they ramp up again
and it's supposed to peak 11 years after
this but but instead of peaking up here
like the previous one it's peaking down
here and so we have actually had a
relatively inactive sunspot cycle in the
past you know this passing spots cycle
it's supposed to be up here we had fewer
sunspots and we're supposed to so the
Sun is actually cooler than it's
supposed to be so the argument that
sunspots are somehow making the climate
warmer are exactly backwards the amount
of sunspots we have is lower than it
should be so if the sunspots were back
up where they ought to be we ought to
see it climate it's even warmer than we
have today so another thing you will
hear from climate change deniers and
these are the people who think that
there either is no climate change or if
it is it's naturally occurring they will
say that volcanic eruptions are what's
behind climate change and usually what
they say is the amount of greenhouse
gases coming out of the volcano is
greater than that of produced by humans
now one reason you already know why
that's not true is because when we
looked at the Keeling curve remember
that that's the curve of co2 going up
and up and up a little bit each year if
the amount of greenhouse gases coming
out of volcanoes was significant then
you would see a big jump every time
there was a volcanic eruption but you
never see that and in fact all the co2
sensors around the world that monitor
how much co2 is in the atmosphere they
don't do anything when you have a big
volcanic eruption it's just not enough
co2 so that's not the reason but there
is a reason that volcanoes can change
the climate if you have a big volcanic
eruption and this is the last really big
one sort of in our lifetime was Pinatubo
in the Philippines in 1991 this big
cloud you see is something called
volcanic ash and it's a little tiny
microscopic pieces of rock and it's
mostly glass and if it's a really big
eruption
material will get ejected up into the
stratosphere and when it gets up into
the stratosphere as we learn in the way
early lecture there is no whether to
remove ash from the stratosphere or
anything from there's no weather up
there there's no causes no precipitation
and so it goes up and it spreads out and
one of the things that it does is it
blocks sunlight and it cools the planet
so for example here's a little
time-lapse movie of a poignant style
eruption and so this is the ash coming
up and you might see some lightning in
there too this looks like the anvil from
a cumulonimbus and this marks the top of
the stratosphere or the I'm sorry the
top of the tropopause in the beginning
of the stratosphere and you can see once
of all you'll see some some ash punching
through and going up into the
stratosphere and so that Ash once it
goes up into the stratosphere will stay
up usually like a couple of years before
it finally gets removed see right there
you can see it going up into the
stratosphere so this will have a change
in the climate but it has a cooling
effect not a warming effect so we have
instruments that actually measure how
much dust is in the stratosphere and
this is the readout from one of these
and let's see if we can make sense of
this so what we're looking at is a graph
let's ignore the color one for now and
we're looking at this black and white
graph this is how much dust is in the
stratosphere as the years go by so this
is 1985 moving forward and we see
there's a big spike right here in the
amount of dust in stratosphere that's
Mount Pinatubo and then it decreases and
takes several years for it to come back
to normal
well during this time in here after
Pinatubo erupted we saw that the world
global temperature decreased about at
one degree or one and a half degrees
centigrade so it actually changed the
climate and you can see these little
bumps here these are smaller volcanic
eruptions that also had put ash into the
stratosphere but at a lesser amount if
you go back in time
you can see that we've actually had some
volcanoes much larger than Pinatubo
every one of these little spikes here
has been a big eruption kind of like the
one we just saw in that movie except
bigger and there has you know for you
know this goes way back hundreds of
years but for the periods of time that
we actually have written records what we
see is that every time there was a
really big eruption like Krakatoa there
was actually a recorded cooing event
afterwards a lot a crop failure you know
in modern times where we actually had
temperature measurements we can measure
that we had a cooler summer that
followed so everyone in these big ones
probably resulted in a in a dip in the
Earth's temperatures for a year or two
following that eruption so if we take
all the sunspot records into account and
we take all the volcanic eruption
records into account we can reconstruct
the climate of the earth in the past
several hundred years and what we see is
that we can explain pretty much all of
the changes in Earth's climate over the
past several hundred years except for
what's happened in the past hundred the
warming that we're seeing in the past
hundred years cannot be explained with
volcanoes or sunspots and we're left
with really the only thing remaining
which is human greenhouse gases